par le nom des joueurs on se souvient
qu'ils sont pas français vous trouvez
des gens sont pas français 1998 l'équipe
de france de football de plus en plus
métis faisait déjà l'objet d' attaque
raciste des propos qui résonnent avec la
sortie récente du sénateur et rennes
stéphane ravier suite au retour de karim
benzema en sélection nationale
karim benzema est français de papier
mais se dit lui-même algérien par le
coeur il n'a qu'à jouer pour l'équipe
algérienne mais les salaires sont bien
moins importants en algérie ont des
premières attaques
c'est celle du leader du front national
jean marie le pen en 1996 je trouve que
c'est tout de même un peu artificielle
de faire venir des joueurs de l'étranger
et de les baptiser équipe de france les
vannes sont ouvertes à chaque
compétition
les sorties xénophobes se font régulière
1998 l'équipe de france est en finale de
son mondial
mais ça n'a pas l'air de suffire à cette
militante du front national quand on y
est l'équipe de france des gens qui
viennent de tous les horizons à diverses
et la france pas du tout parce qu'à
cette fois ci en face pour pas prendre
est déjà derrière 2006 nouvelle coupe du
monde est encore une fois des joueurs
français sont victimes de parole raciste
derrière ces mots choquants encore jean
marie le pen interviewé par l' agence de
presse reuters
déclare on sent que la france se
reconnaît pas totalement dans cette
équipe ou encore
peut-être que le sélectionneur a exagéré
la proportion de joueurs de couleur
peut-être qu'il aurait dû garder dans ce
domaine là plus de mesures peut-être
s'est-il laissé entraîner par ses choix
idéologiques en juin 2010 à quelques
jours du début de la coupe du monde en
afrique du sud
marine le pen s'y mettent aussi la
numéro deux du fn est l'invité de
jean-jacques bourdin sur bfmtv le pognon
qui dégouline de ces gens
le sentiment de cet argent facilement
gagné à coup ils sont représentants de
la france quand ils sont quand ils sont
à la coupe du monde un autre coup
guichot considère comme appartenant à
une autre nation ou ayant une autre
nationalité de coeur
après marine le pen marion maréchal-le
pen le 1er juin 2016 karim benzema n'est
pas retenu pour l'euro
il déclare que didier deschamps a cédé
sous la pression d'une partie raciste de
la france la députée d'extrême droite
réagit et attaque benzema avec ce tweet
l'algérie c'est mon pays la france c'est
juste pour le côté sportif qu'il a joué
dans son pays s'il n'est pas content
mais ses sorties xénophobe ne sont pas
exclusives au parti d'extrême droite
en 2006 c'est une personnalité de gauche
qui se distinguent
georges frêche président de la région
languedoc-roussillon se lâche
complètement dans le quotidien midi
libre
dans cette équipe il ya neuf blacks sur
onze la normalité serait qu'il y en ait
trois ou quatre ce serait le reflet de
la société
mais là s'il y en a autant c'est que les
blancs sont nuls j'ai honte pour ce pays
suite à ces propos georges frêche et
exclu du parti socialiste
[Musique]